みなさんこんにちは
皆さんごはん食べました
ちょっとでもそうな顔していらっしゃるかというかもしれないですけど
アジアし私はかねばと純一と言います今日は私の研究である
共有楽器というものについて私の考え方をみなさんにご紹介したいと思います
突然ですがみなさん楽器焼きますかだ休憩方ちょっとてあげてみてください
家バリバリますそれでは
いきたいと思ったことありませんか
そうそこですごくてはあるんですねぇ
とても面白いです私は楽器が好きです
そして人前で演奏するのが好きです
大学時代はヤンチャくるでしたこんな感じで気を嗅ぐというところですが
ベースをやっていたんです
古賀演奏も好きなんですけど自分の演奏を見て楽しむ
そういう間少々見るのが大好きなんです
そして今回のテーマである音楽の素晴らしさはもう一つあります
ゲームを超えることができるんです
これは僕があっ
オーストリアに留学した時組んでいたセッションバンド
インターラクティブバンドの様子です
どんなリズムでどんな音階どんな妙 d で聖書んするのか
東 j or つながった私はいえ後でもってその感情を伝えることができませんでし
た
よどーでしょ楽器を考えてかき鳴らすだけで
音楽で
言葉のいらないのです
その時の研究のこのときの経験が私の今の楽器の研究につながっているんです
私は楽器インターフェース研究者として活動しています
インターフェイスっていうのは何かと何か設定のことを指します
私は楽器というものを通して人と人をつなぐ
そんな研究しているんです研究の対象は県庁舎だけではありません
小学障害な視覚障害その他様々も障害を持った人も対象にしているんです
さて私ガッキーが少し弾けると自己紹介しました
今ここにアコースティックギターはあります
僕ギター彦部ビジネスもん
スコア銀原画をすぎるじゃないですか
というのが難しいですよね変な音が出ちゃったら恥ずかしい
総合から
ギター敷けない
そこで私こんな楽器作りました満点ギターというギターです
今ショット見てみてください
ゲームはありませんどうやって自分がちょっとやってみましょう
これ今-羽根で音はなう
音の高さを変えたいその時は僕いい
本体を構える高さを変えるんです
空間上に五線譜はあるようなイメージですね
うーん
なんだ者音を傾けたプー
今回を傾ければいいです
音を揺らしたりその時はいい
元田れっぱなしだとますのでも
と見ながらそれでも風
はぁっ
ありがとうございます
いいいい
このマウンテンギターのおかげで僕は人前でギター愛するはという日ができました
このように私がこれから紹介する共有楽器というのは作業手を上げていただいた皆さん
音楽や演奏を楽しむモチベーションをみなさんに当たることができるそうあたしゃ信じ
てます
潮位楽器
これは私が作り出した造語です
共に遊ぶと抱きます
誰と誰が一緒に遊んのか
私は障害のある人と編成社は一緒に遊ぶ
それを共有楽器で実現したいと考えています
私は以前玩具会社で玩具の企画をやっていました
世の中にどんなおもちゃがあるか調べるリサーチという段階でこの
おもちゃに出会ったんですオセロ
恐れをやったことある人
えっ
ありがとうございますそうほとんど屋やってますよね
でも重くせろって普通のせるとひと味違うんです
次のスライドを見てみたい
駒野何か勝ちうまいですよねちょっと見てみましょう
白いコマは真っ平らう
黒いコマには円形のテクスチャーがあるんです
これでできること
例えば私が命が見えなかったら
オセロの駒がどこにあるのかそれが白が黒なのかわからない
でもこの工夫によって健常者と視覚障害者が一緒に寄せるが遊べるんです
このように障害者と健常者の遊びを計上とか
昨日のデザインで解決するそういうアプローチが共有の概念です
すでに世の中に共有ダウンと言われるものは
提案され製品とだって
いろいろな人々に喜びを届けています
しかし
共有学校っていうのは今まであまり提案されていないんです
それはなぜでしょうか
楽器や音楽は主に
意味で楽しいん
そんな固定概念にとらわれているからではないでしょうか
27万6000人
現在日本国内にいる聴覚障害の数です
およそ1,000人に32の割合です
この中には加齢による老人性の難聴は含まれていません
つまり実際にはもっと多くの人々が聞こえに対して問題を抱えているのです
この問題に対して楽器がどうアプローチするかそういったことを考えていきたいと
おもいます
私は玩具会社の後大学で助手をしていました
その時に小学唱歌長岳障害を持った学生と話をする機会有りました
音楽や音が教育に対してい
彼女はこう言っていました
音楽を楽しみたいそんな気持ちがあるんだけど
手がかりがない
そして
音楽の授業はとても退屈なものだった
そう言っていました
そんな人たちのために私は今日医学切手いうものを提案したいのです
聴覚障害者が楽しめる楽器を作ることでもっと多くの人が
音楽に対して積極的になれるそう信じています
ここで一人のアーティストを紹介します
この方は聴覚障害を持ちながらも全世界的に活躍される
パーカッショニストのエヴェリングレニーさんです
管理の素敵なトークやパフォーマンスさ
鉄塔のホームページで見ることができます
12歳で音楽を始めた彼女
その彼女に対して音楽の先生をはじめ
このように言いました
音は右を通して聞くものだよだから君には難しいかもしれん
それに対してへベリーさんこのように話します
先生
私は右側にもケア腕脚
棟
身体全体を使って音楽を感じているの
そして
葉っぱ滝から落ちその瞬間に私は音をイメージすることができる
だから私は大丈夫だろうそう答えたそうです
皆さん
音楽は耳だけで楽しいものでしょうか
えべりーさんのこれらの言葉から私はそれに対してノーと答えたりです
さてここで
コンサートホールで聴く音楽そして家のオーディオで聴く音楽を比較してみましょう
例えば皆さんこんな経験ありませんか
コンサートホールデー
ものすごく良い音楽を聴いたあの感動家でをもう一度味わいたい
あ今指示があった買って帰ろ買って帰って家のおいおい再生してみた
でもコンサートホールで味わった感動が再現できないのはなぜでしょうか
人は肌でも空気振動で音を感じているんです
コンサートホールやライブハウスツアー
音を右や肌で感じれるように最適化された空間なのです
振動は本能に直接訴えかけ
音楽の感動を引き起こす非常に重要な要素です
それだったら好き顔にをあげればいいじゃないだ
そう思われる方々もいらっしゃいでしょ
コンサートホールには他の大事な要素があるのです
例えば
演奏者の動きや目線
そういった細かい動きに目を配る
そして素晴らしい音楽と空間を共にした人たちと味はこの一帯ターン
音という現象を共有する喜び3
それは決して家で聴く音楽では味わうことができません
ピアニストであり指揮者であった裏でビールアシュケナージはこのように行きます
音楽の本質は共有である
音を見以外で感じて他の人と共有することで障害の有無にかかわらず
みんなで音楽を楽しむことができるのではないか
私はそう考えたんです
音楽は耳だけでなく
資格
触覚
様々な感覚で楽しむ総合芸術だと捉えます
この考えから私は音を耳以外の感覚でも楽しめて体験を共有できる
障害を持った方と健常者が共に遊べる楽器を提案します
ここで一つ
作った研究を紹介したいと思います
音に触ることができるそんなアプローチがあります
テルーのが楽器で家の箱を叩くか今と言われる楽器があります
これは日ブラションカホンディバージョンというなすというのでバイブレーション振動
のことです
津波に叩くと
こんなことになるんです
それでは映像を見ながら詳しく紹介しています
これは3人で一緒にパク楽器です
一人が太鼓を叩いた時その音が振動に変換されて他の2人に使うわけです
たとえば文字長くの方とここでプレーしていることも打楽器がグループ
ここでプレイしている人な書やぶるぶる
音と振動を共有するそんな機能を持っているんです
もう一つの機能があります
3人でセッションしているとき叩くタイミング合う瞬間がある
その瞬間
より大きな振動がお互いに伝わるのです
あっ今の瞬間ただ来た意味があったんだね
それが耳だけではな肌を通して感じることができるのです
ビブラしょん缶を使って検証実験を行いました
2のかほんとユラシャンカホンそれらを比較したときに振動がある時とない時心臓が
あった時の方が相手をより近くに感じ
一緒に演奏しているという感覚が向上することが明らかになっています
三浦俊が方を考えるきっかけ
実は満点ギターにあるんです
このマウンテンギターというのは幸いにも色々な人に楽しまれるそんな機会に恵まれ
ました
検事と言われ3月です
そこで体験してくれた方がある事いいました
ううぅ rrrrr
の楽器音格好して面白いんだけど
聞いている感覚がなくてなんか違和感があるんだ
する言葉を聞いたときに私は
それでは抜去引いている感覚がどこにあるのか
それを考えるに至りました
マウンテンギターを弾いとっていい
本体からの振動はほとんど帰って来ません
アコースティックのがあっていっ
ああああああうん
振動が腕を伝って身体全体に伝わっています
この振動と言われるものが演奏の実感にとても大きな役割を果たしている
そう思ったんです
ではこの振動をみんなで共有したら一緒に演奏している
そんな感覚が強くなるのではないかと考えたのがきっかけです
私は元会社に勤めながら研究活動を続けました
聾学校の音楽の授業の中で実際にこの打楽器を使用してもらい利用者から生の声を聞き
より良い体験方法について考えました
数々の体験の場の中で最も私の心を動かした言葉
それはこの日ぶらしょんか頬に触れたことが子供が音が聞こえたと言ってくれたこと
です
その子供は聴覚障害を持っていました
音は耳だけで感じるものではない
そういった持論が確信を得た瞬間でもあります
今回は残念ながら皆さんに楽器の振動を体験したいとはことは難しいので
いまの最新の研究をとを見て楽しむアプローチを紹介したいと思います
この演奏ゴラム高さ
me
楽器を叩く等
その叩く強さによって後ろにある映像が変化しているのかなと思います
強く叩けば叩く円の大きさが大きくなる
これは音を見て心配はございません
これにより聴覚に障害がある人
リズムの掛け合いコミュニケーション面白さを目で見て楽しむことができます
普通の
それではみなさんと一緒にお供見る体験をしてみたいと思います
皆さんこのデバイスを持っていますか
ありがとうございますそれではこれの付け方を説明します
皆さん手のひらを自分の正面に向けてみてください
そこに対してロゴが見えるように
を置きますそのままこれを中指にと申します
そうこんな感じ
それでは拍手をしてみましょう
難波5でしょ
センターがしたっていうのが分かれています
このプラフライトというのは指にはめて拍手することで拍手のエネルギーを led の
光に変換することができます
この薄い本体の中電池は入っていません
手と手がぶつかるエネルギーで転倒するんです
素子が壊れない限り永久に使えることができます
それでは皆さんちょっと拍手で遊びましょうこの泉ます
皆さんお互いの拍手が見えると思います
音楽の自分に乗ったとき思わず拍手でリズムをとってしまうそんな行為に着目したもの
です
コンサートホールは観客席ガーダ薄暗いことがあります
このリングをはめることで
聴覚に障害を持った人も
全体がどんなリズムで盛り上がっているのか目で見て感じることができます
私は聴覚障害者と一緒に共有楽器の研究を行ってきました
その中では
には聞こえること聞こえないことは
音楽の真の楽しさを味わう会はあまり関係ないことがわかってきたんです
私の好きな言葉を最後に紹介します
you have 実は6時 i 発生
あなたにはあなたの音楽がある
私もそうである
この言葉が示すように音楽には右だけではない
肌で感じるそして見た目を楽しむ
それぞれの楽しみ方があるのです
共有楽器によって耳の聞こえに関係なく音楽を楽しむことができる
私はその信じています
さまざまな人が同じ場所にいて同じ音楽という現象を楽しむ
リズムを通してつながるそんな楽しいと共演できるのがこの教諭がって何です
これからも色々な人と音楽の楽しいや喜びそういったものを追求するために共有楽器を
作り続け
広めていきたいとおもいます
皆さんもぜひ耳だけではない音の感じ方について考えてみてください
そこから新しい共有のアイディアが生まれてくるかもしれません
最後に私はこんな自由な格好をして同じような髪型で自由に研究貼らせていただいて
いるのは
研究を支えてくれる両親や家族そして同じく同僚の研究者の
おかげだと思っています
ありがとうございました